these volunteers want to regain the lost
beauty of their city
they're removing rubbish littering the
banks of the tigris river in baghdad
to make it cleaner and healthier we will
keep going until
everybody gets the message until people
realize that
it's our civil responsibility to take
care of our public places and to protect
them to not throw trash that throwing
trash on the street in the river is an
offense even if currently the law
doesn't
penalize you for it that we should use
have our own morals and our own
discipline to to protect these places
the river banks are a breathing space
for many here in iraq's capital
especially those in its suburbs
but with rubbish pining up in several
cities along the river
and with it becoming increasingly
polluted
groups like this are out to get levels
of waste down
this amount of rubbish can also be
reduced
by making
people more aware of the river's
importance to ecology and for recreation
that could help reduce littering
but the river would still remain
contaminated by other activities
like wastewater
with neglected infrastructure tons of
garbage and waste fall into the river
including metals and debris
and even dead animals
some waste breaks down and forms harmful
micro plastics
safe transfers passengers between the
river banks on his boat
it's a family business he inherited from
his father but it's now in decline
it is my second home but i feel bad
every day when i watch all these
polluters around people have become less
attracted to boat tours and tourism is
now zero
with population growth and urban
expansion in baghdad
more sewage and waste is being
discharged into the river
healthy facilities oil installations
factories and laboratories
all dump toxic waste directly into the
tigris
officials say the amount of
contamination is alarming the is
there are 25 sewage plants in baghdad
discharging directly into the river
without treatment a permanent solution
to this requires transformation of the
whole sewage system in baghdad that
means a lot of money and effort it could
take years
the tigris is a main source of drinking
water in baghdad
and these volunteers want to restore its
cleanliness and vitality
and encourage others across iraq to do
the same
al jazeera